[Música]
es aquí en mí que se terminó la
peregrinación penitencial del papá los
alumnos de las escuelas residenciales
gracias
por lo que tuvieron la valentía de decir
compartiendo grandes sufrimientos
que yo no hubiera imaginado
eso ha reavivado en mí la indignación
y la vergüenza
que me acompañan desde hace meses es 1
punto y se vino para encontrarse con
supervivientes de los internados
católicos y pedirles perdón como ya lo
hizo en varios lugares de canadá durante
su semana de viaje pero aún queda mucho
camino para recorrer según algunos
miembros de estos pueblos originarios
de la disculpa no era una disculpa
completa ya que no es en el sexo
no reconoció ningún abuso sexual y no
reconoció el papel institucional de los
católicos romanos en la protección de
los abusadores
esta protección permite que la violencia
sexual prospere
entre 1880 y 1996 más de 150.000
indígenas fueron alejados de sus hogares
y enviados a internados que pretendían
asimilar los culturalmente en estas
escuelas muchos sufrieron de abuso
físico sexual y emocional miles de ellos
nunca volvieron gamer bueno aquí no sé a
pedir perdón no lo sé al menos 9 mi
padre mi versión la etapa del papá en el
ártico canadiense cultura una visita
oficial de seis días un paso clave en
los esfuerzos del vaticano para
reconciliarse con las comunidades
nativas de américa del norte pero
también un viaje que reveló la
deteriorada salud del sumo pontífice
cuyos dolores le obligaron a utilizar
una silla de ruedas para desplazarse